Welcome back to the show, remember that we
are mostly funded by individual memberships,
one of which you can get at, join Pakman Dotcom.
That also gets you the daily bonus show more
show every day. For those who choose it, sign
up at Join Pakman dot com. So we learned this
weekend that Donald Trump will be fighting
back against ISIS, Twitter and Facebook and
cancel culture. I don't know, by making
a triumphant return to social media
in two to three months on his own platform.
Maybe it will be called Trump Book, or maybe it
will be called Twit Trump or Trump or Graham. Who
knows? Here is perpetual, never ending infinity.
Trump brownnoser. Jason Miller explaining
this on Fox News just a couple of days ago.
Donald Trump obviously has been booted off Twitter
and Facebook and Instagram, which were a great
megaphone for him. Does he plan to try to get back
on social media, perhaps with some new outfit?
You know how this is really interesting and the
fact the president's been off of social media
for a while because his press releases, his
statements have actually been getting almost
more play than he ever did on Twitter before.
Now, that's completely untrue. Jason Miller,
as usual, is lying. Trump having the bully pulpit
on Twitter dwarfed those bizarre, sometimes almost
sad and pathetic press releases he's been
putting out. But that's not the key part here.
The key part is Jason Miller telling us
Trump is launching a social media network.
I'm not sure if that's because the
length of them are a bit longer. Even had
one reporter saying that she thought it was
much more elegant, the way the president was
able to communicate his thoughts and very much
looked more presidential in that longer form.
But I do think that we're going to see President
Trump returning to social media and probably
about two or three months here with his own
platform. And this is something that I think
will be the the hottest ticket in social media.
It's going to completely redefine the game
and everybody is going to be waiting and
watching to see what exactly President
Trump does. But it will be his own platform. So
just to follow up, will this be a platform that
the president and the former president will create
himself, will be working with another company
and obviously he'll be starting from scratch. He
won't start out with 88 million Twitter followers?
Well, I can't go much further than what I was able
to just share, but I can say that it will be big
once he starts. There have been a lot of high
powered meetings he's been having at Mar a Lago
with some teams of folks who have been coming
in. And I got to tell you, there have been
it's not just one company that's approached the
president. There have been numerous companies.
But I think the president does know what
direction that he wants to head here.
And this new platform is going to
be big and everyone wants him. He's
going to bring millions and millions, tens
of millions of people to this new platform.
Look at the hyperbole. It will be
the hottest ticket in social media,
even hotter maybe, I guess, than
parlor and gab.
And I love the reference to high
powered meetings with teams of folks.
Teams of folks have been flocking to Mar a Lago
for high powered meetings. So anyway, it's very
clear that Donald
Trump is in various ways testing whether he
should or could successfully run in twenty twenty
four. Part of that is what Donald Trump announced
at that CPAC speech at the end of February
that you can donate to his PAC, Save America,
and he will play kingmaker. Don't donate to the
Republican Party. If you donate to the Republican
Party, they might put money towards so-called
rhinos. Republicans in name only. Trump doesn't
like people like Mitt Romney. Trump, if you donate
to him, will decide which Republicans are worthy
of support. He will primary the bad Republicans
that he has identified. He will support the pro
Trump Republicans. And as we said before, if he
can do that, if he can wield that degree of power,
it helps him to
look stronger for twenty twenty four here.
Of course, recognizing that Twitter was a big
part of his winning in 2016 in the first place,
being absent on Twitter now because he's banned,
he's going to try to create an alternative,
all with the same purpose to regain that
power and to rebuild his bully pulpit. Now,
will it actually happen? Because remember that
back in August of twenty, twenty or July even,
we were just two weeks away from getting Trump's
new health care plan, which he was going to roll
out. It was going to be perfect. It was going
to be signed into law. It was going to replace
Obamacare. Never came out. And Donald Trump's
gone. And back in 2015, Donald Trump said he
would release his tax returns and he never did.
So lots of things that Trump claims he will do or
others claim Trump will do never end up happening.
I have no idea. It may happen. It may not. What we
can be absolutely certain of is that if Donald.
Trump does launch a social media platform,
it will
very quickly become a central node
of disinformation, propaganda. It's also funny to
hear Jason Miller say Trump is going to redefine
social media. It's always so endlessly hyperbolic.
It's the same thing they said about Trump's
presidency now. In a sense, Trump redefined the
presidency to the point of bad in showing how
corrupt a president could be, but redefining
it in terms of finally draining the swamp and
changing everything, you know, OK, he was the most
corrupt administrator in the modern political era,
but that's not exactly a change I'd be bragging
about. So maybe we'll see more of the same with
the social media thing. Maybe it'll just never
happen as so many of the things that are promised
never do. But the latest is Trump will return
with his own social media platform. Let me know
what you think it should be called.
I'm terrible at this stuff.
Trump, Graham and Trump book is the only
thing I could come up with because I'm
just completely uncreative. But I know
some of you will have some better ideas.